Psychopaths,
I don't,
I say this,
I hope non naively also having dealt
with psychopaths in my clinical practice
and I would say now and then in my life,
I don't believe in psychopaths.
I don't believe that we know enough to
say there are people born without
conscience.
Um,
I don't think the psychometric
measurement of psychopathy is everything
that it should be.
I've been trying to model it bay in the
big five domain.
I think now it's complicated because,
so I would say a psychopath,
the classic psychopath is likely
extroverted,
especially assertive,
disagreeable and unconscientious and
maybe extremely low in neuroticism.
So you can't frighten them.
But so that's a rare combination because
it's extreme on many traits,
right?
But that,
I don't believe that that means that
someone with that personality
configuration is doomed from birth to a
pathological existence because there's
things about psychopathy that,
that the,
that the classifiers,
those who claim like collectively that
the psychopath is born in some sense
can't explain.
It's like,
well,
what about the cruelty?
It seems to be a motive there.
You know,
with our passionless and they lack,
they lack emotion.
Well,
why are they cruel then for
entertainment?
Well,
but then you have to explain the
entertainment motivation,
like there's a failure in some sense
with the classic psychopathy theorists
to come to grips with the problem of
malevolence.
It's skirted over and you can't do that.
If you're talking about psychopathy,
it's like malevolence is the bloody
issue here.
And so
the other issue with this psychopath is
that he's irredeemable,
right?
That's the idea.
I don't think we know enough to make
such claims now and that doesn't.
I know the psychopathy literature quite
well and I have great respect for their
primary researchers in the field.
I want to make that perfectly clear,
but we're talking at a different.
We're talking,
we're approaching the problem from a
different level of analysis here.
Something like a spiritual level of
analysis and I don't think that there's
an easy,
easy translation from the descriptive
psychometric psychiatric approach to the
spiritual level.
They don't match and I'm more likely to
say let's not assume the soul is doomed
from birth.
Right?
And I'm,
I'm loath to think that there are people
born irredeemable.
Although I do think there are
irredeemable people knew that the death
penalty issues interesting in that
regard,
you know,
because I've read a lot about really
terrible people and I've also read a lot
about what really terrible people said
about themselves and many of them wished
for the death penalty and so it's
absolutely clear that there are things
that you can do that deserved the death
penalty,
but that doesn't mean that the state
should have the right to impose it.
That's a different question,
so yeah,
thank you.